hello winter welcome to this video
playing Frankie J so I'm playing my line
and see what happens with Hansel castles
yes if we get it in it's not like blegh
wins but it is I mean it's no question
was having more fun now and one thing is
first glance you think like okay is
black going insane yeah but the second
glance you would why do you see oh my
god this is actually dangerous same
happen to me when I analyze this for
white okay so i can take this now or
take G fine I think I'll take your first
then take you five
you
this absolutely horrific the plane blitz
for white even in a normal game this is
not easy and then blitz chess oh my god
so let's see how he tries to defend us
95 maybe some something actor firm on c7
yeah it's not like checkmated
immediately here mmm but I like you to
try to try to get some counter play so
um how am I going to play Bishop g4
maybe 997 then should not work but we
should reform that looks like the temple
gainer I can't castle long you know if I
can casts a long it would be cool just
like protect c7 while castling long and
some stuff probably doesn't work here or
we should we have three that Queen yeah
maybe he can play with it Queen age 41
rook rook e1
might work even though we bishop i think
i can take and casts a long that's not a
bad position for black okay one one one
good thing is that i'm ahead on the
clock buyer by a long long shot so he
played pushed by three young Queen edge
for Queen edge for Brooke clean edge to
check and then I can check on age three
and then cast long he goes all the way
to eat true them I think flicking this
in shouldn't be bad anyway let's do it
so I can check on edge to check on h3
and he goes to eat too but then there is
actually the threat of route h1
okay I'll take this no castle the thing
is that d4 hangs and it's not such an
easy way for him to to handle this i
believe
taking only five is completely wrong so
he took it takes wow so he's got to
check here but night age I was made on
air mater mate checkmate this is
actually bad but I didn't see it if it
the maid meeting idea ok that's it I
have to really look at him
check definitely do want to trade queens
in check
I still don't believe in wats position
yeah I mean for porn um this is a great
great compensation crook here on takes
takes into the bishop and I can probably
thick with this okay so this one on
threatening look h2 what is she doing
against it look II to on old g8 is that
actually better not so easy hope 28
threatens an immediate made on each one
I was thinking just rotate g3 here takes
Queen takes maybe escapes ye tool or the
net Chicago check there I think this is
that this is defendable threaten all
kinds of things kounya 30 gauge one made
if he goes to each way check here on g2
and then move da check yeah this is
called estimators striking I don't think
it was possible to defend it hope that
it's an absolutely um killing line I
mean it's objectively bad for widen it
in blitz chests is absolutely an
absolute best to play actually debate if
we text g5 a stronger at the engine
actually says that this is stronger yeah
but okay this was wasn't bad either now
25 really seems to be better but anyway
let's have a look at the actual game
played 95 and this this insertion is at
least first quick calculation good by
the engine so here 24 okie one yeah now
i will have the check but y'all here
this is for good yeah i'm having killed
myself yeah that doesn't work my queen
has no squares so the engine wants to
play like i did so that wasn't too bad
97 cop okay so I time it do it do it
badly and c5 Rudy
eight now instead of taking yeah DFA
threatens made as well but I thought why
not take and probably cannot save it
it's just too bad quickie for ok but
this winds as well right it's made it's
too much I'm attacking with too many
pieces and then this is simply not
playing at all I mean Here I am actually
attacking just with rook and queen but
it's enough it's really enough White's
King position is just too bad gather
bottom line is that castles it's not a
good move here because of age 53 too
dangerous why should play a slow move a
3 root B 1 something something like that
ok guys thanks for watching